- We all know you.
- I know, I know.
Okay, so I'm gonna talk about chemo-less,
not chemo-free approaches for elderly patients
with newly diagnosed large-term lymphoma.
I was giving this talk because we have a trial concept
in startup at UCLA.
That's what I'm gonna talk about,
but that's the last slide.
So we have to get through the other ones to get there.
So what do we know?
Jörn Chapuis' data at ASH,
the r-polar-glow combination chemo,
not quite chemo-free, it's chemo-mini,
in newly diagnosed elderly patients
not deemed to be candidates for full-dose chemo.
Those data represented at ASH were quite impressive.
So patients receive six cycles of combination
polar glufidamab and rituxan.
And then after six cycles, they continue for another 12,
for a total of 12 cycles of glufidamab
for a total of 12-month, 12-cycle treatment course.
And for principle to the left,
patient with a lot of disease within two weeks
of this Vegemin achieved a complete remission.
That was nice to see.
And if you see on the right,
these are data at post-cycle two,
post-cycle six, and post-cycle 12.
The CR rates started to improve from 58 to 81%.
And also at the bottom on the right,
you see the relapses started to occur as well.
So, but those data were rather,
rather striking for an almost chemo free regimen
for a patient with aggressive diffuse HB cell lymphoma.
And of course we need more follow-up to know
if these responses are durable,
but the one-year progression-free survival,
one-year overall survival rates as shown here,
I look really, really good with 84 and 90,
89% overall survival rate.
So how about,
what do you think about the tolerability?
So on the left patient had a grade three infection, 19%.
Three patients died.
Mainly COVID was blamed for that, one was unknown.
And if you look about infections over time,
they had activity in the beginning of the first cycle,
then kind of tapered off.
But I think we have to keep an eye
on the follow-up infectious complications far on the right.
Seem to pile up infections there,
but of course the more time you wait,
the more you collect.
But I think we'll need to see how doable the efficacy is
and how much side effects we get with infections over time.
How about Epcotamab plus our mini CHOP for elderly patients?
Those data were shown at ASH as well.
Here it was time limited course, six,
six cycles of combination where Epcot and mini CHOP
was being given from the get-go.
And then the cycle seven, cycle eight,
monotherapy with Epcotamab, and then the treatment stops.
So this combination therapy, shorter time course,
again, elderly patients not deemed candidates
for aggressive full dose CHOP.
And so the overall response rates and CRR rates
were what you expected, they looked great, 86% CRR.
CRR rates, 93% overall response rate.
And we'll have to see what the longer follow-up will show.
In terms of, and that's progressively survival,
overall survival data here,
what you would expect in terms of safety,
there was no surprises.
Actually, CRS rates were low, grade one, grade two,
maybe being protected.
Patients, when you give five days of steroids
and chemotherapy at the same time that you,
administer bispecifics, some neutropenia, but not too much.
That's all kind of side effects that one would expect
in this patient population, no surprises there.
And again, CRS, as you would see with single agent
bispecifics, you see the uptake of CRS
with the first full dose, which is at cycle one, day 15,
mainly grade one, grade two events.
So this was very surprising data to me.
And we have seen more of this early this morning,
the morning sun data, mozutuzumab for elderly patients.
These patients only received a time-limited course
of mozutuzumab for newly diagnosed diffusor,
Spitzel, and for many progression-free
and over survival data, look rather promising.
Of course, the follow-up is short,
but I do have two patients that run this trial.
One of them, who had been in a coma for more than a year,
and the second patient, who had been in a coma for more than a year,
and the third patient, who had been in a coma for more than a year,
and the fourth patient, who had been in a coma for more than a year,
and the fifth patient, who had been in a coma for more than a year,
and the sixth patient, who had been in a coma for more than a year,
and the seventh patient, who had been in a coma for more than a year,
right now. So I want to take advantage of the intact immune system, giving biospecifics without
giving anything else that inhibits them first. So patients receive two cycles of epcridomab
in order to make this more palatable in terms of side effects. And they get one dose of Polar,
one dose of Rituxan prior to that. A little bit of tumour debulking, but also getting rid of
circulating B-cells to some degree to diminish the side effect risk. And then patients with
cycle three continue with epcridomab, but we dial in Polar mini-CHP.
And if patients achieve a complete remission after two cycles of the culmination of
Polar mini-CHP and epcridomab, so it's cycle four total, then we have the option of stopping the
chemo-containing.
If a patient's lymphoma grows right through epcridomab in the first two cycles, we can start
the Polar mini-CHP at any point. And we will have serial MRD testing along the way to inform us
about the speed of tumour burden response by MRD testing through collaboration.
And yeah, I said that. So if we have the option of not only,
reducing the amount of chemotherapy we're giving with a mini CHP approach, but also reducing the
amount of chemotherapy cycles we administer. So the idea, therefore, is to emphasise immunotherapy
and de-emphasise chemotherapy and find just the right dose of chemotherapy, not too much and not
too little. And finding the right balance between time-limited effective treatment and also avoiding
open-ended immunotherapy with Prozac. So that's the first step. The second step is to find the
potentially toxicities and that was it.